impeachment has reached a new level of
nastiness did you hear what happened
today
good let's go no one wants to hear ya
let's all get on a bus and go to a bar
please I don't have that kind of money
no it's reached a new level of nastiness
today President Trump sent a scathing
letter to House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
really nasty scathing letter yeah
Trump ended the letter with if you like
me check yes ahead HBO's The Watchmen
aired its season finale on Sunday
critics are saying the first season and
did so perfectly the show should not be
renewed they're actually saying that
they're saying that the finale was so
perfect they shouldn't make any more of
the shows yeah ladies gentlemen either
reason I've been on the air for 26
[Applause]
the trick is never be that good you know
always leave room Oh we leave become
Nixon again it's been reported that in
the upcoming film version of cats you're
gonna see that Andy oh no absolutely now
I will while not be seeing it eat oh boy
and I shouldn't say that we should have
a look might look ahead there might be
some people from the cast coming on the
show and that this may be terrible but
no I'm not seeing that the show are a
Taylor Swift yeah yeah what a blow to
Taylor Swift Conan and Andy won't be
seeing well moving cows now it's been
reported that in the upcoming film
version of cats the editors digitally
removed an actor's penis yeah yeah yeah
when asked about it the actor said I
wish they'd done it digitally
you're honest I know they cut his dick
off that deserves a nice parliamentary
applause I believe that's called
neutering yeah